sono nata e cresciuta in italia con un
cognome straniero quando ero al liceo mi
dissero che non avrei avuto una
sufficienza in italiano perché era
un'immigrata non capivo perché io
dovessi essere etichettata per il mio
cognome quando ci fecero imparare il 12
artico e la costituzione che riassumono
i principi fondamentali del nostro paese
rimasi piacevolmente sorpresa
dall'articolo numero 3 tutti i cittadini
hanno pari dignità sociale e sono uguali
davanti alla legge senza distinzione di
sesso di razza di lingua di religione di
opinioni politiche di condizioni
personali o sociali
l'articolo aggiunge inoltre che è
proprio compito della repubblica
rimuovere gli ostacoli di ordine
economico e sociale che limitano di
fatto la libertà e l'uguaglianza
cittadini impediscono il pieno sviluppo
della persona umana
si è dunque come si applicava questo
articolo e come si prevedeva la tutela
di queste persone ma non ebbe una
risposta nel 2015 quando mi professore
all'università mi disse che ormai è
troppo tardi e che il cambiamento
climatico avrebbe portato con sé
cambiamenti irreversibili per noi e per
il pianeta
mi chiesi se anche in quel caso ci
sarebbe stato un diritto che sancisse
almeno teoricamente la tutela
dell'ambiente a livello internazionale
studiai attentamente tutti i trattati
firmati e stipulati in quegli anni
ma proprio come l'articolo 3 della
costituzione italiana non prevedeva la
tutela mia e delle persone con cui nome
straniero e provenienze straniere anche
il diritto internazionale non tutelava
l'ambiente se non tramite dinamiche
negoziali e inter governative che in
gergo economico potremmo definire
soluzioni di second best nel corso della
mia giovane vita ho scoperto che per un
cognome straniero in italia è un po come
incarnare la biodiversità nel xxi secolo
poche tutele e molto pregiudizio dunque
la grande sfida di oggi rimane non
parlare solo di diritti ma anche ben
ruolo fondamentale dei nostri doveri
poi mi vedrete allora qual è il nostro
dovere qual è la soluzione alla
eliminazione e al cambiamento climatico
in realtà esistono 1 tanti singoli
obiettivi da attuare e quindi non una
sola cosa da fare
2 che proprio all'azione il fattore
determinante nel caso il cambiamento
climatico
durante gli anni sono state delineate
varie scale interventi possibili e
percorsi verso la sostenibilità
ambientale
ad oggi possiamo dire che una prima
soluzione un primo pacchetto di proposte
lo abbiamo già si chiama green economy
la green economy è un modo per
ricostruire il nostro futuro dando
priorità al pianeta e alle persone
com'è possibile
da un lato dobbiamo ridurre le emissioni
di co2 in atmosfera
il consumo del suolo e la produzione dei
rifiuti anche cercando di intervenire
nella creazione di reti virtuose di con
mia circolare
dall'altra è necessario
aumentare l'efficienza delle risorse
rinnovabili
per fare tutto questo dobbiamo agire a
livello locale dando i giusti mezzi alle
persone e aiutando lo sviluppo delle
città e dei centri urbani
la risposta al cambiamento climatico e
che noi abbiamo già una risposta
dobbiamo adottare un approccio integrato
e multisettoriale che renda lo sviluppo
sostenibile in modo tale da proteggere
l'ambiente
e qui solitamente quando dico che si
interviene qualcuno che nella vita non
vissuta e sicuramente più di me 16
scusami ma questi giovani speranzosa non
sa in realtà tutto questo ha un costo
aggiunto ma lo status quo e la non
azione hanno un costo ben più elevato
milioni di vite miliardi di euro per
cercare di arginare le catastrofi
naturali
instabilità politica e migrazioni clima
che il costo della donazione è ben più
elevato ma per un illogico motivo la
dimensione reale del riscaldamento
globale è molto difficile da abbracciare
col pensiero razionale ed è qui che la
crisi climatica si scontra con una serie
di giudizi che riducono a zero la
propensione a un cambiamento radicale
dei nostri sistemi hill costellazione
sarà sicuramente elevato nel breve
periodo ma nel lungo periodo avremmo
sicuramente dei benefici in termini
monetari e sociali e ambientali
e allora voi mi chiederete come si può
parlare della crisi del pianeta in modo
tale da renderlo appetibile in realtà ci
basterebbe sapere che l'attività umana è
l'unica vera responsabile del
riscaldamento globale avvenuto
dall'inizio della rivoluzione
industriale ad oggi
ma questa è quella che lo scrittore e
climatologo cost definisce la grande
città ovvero l'essere incapace di vedere
ciò che si sta manifestando davanti a
noi ogni giorno e noi che ci siamo
dentro come esseri umani dobbiamo
cercare di fuggire dalle trappole
logiche ci siamo creati nella comunità
del nostro quotidiano e cercare di
spingere per la creazione di un futuro
che si basi sulla sostenibilità
ambientale ma anche sul rispetto diritti
umani siamo ciechi di fronte a cose e ci
riguardano e pronto riusciamo a vederle
anche perché chi avrebbe dovuto
insegnarci le realtà le ignora per molto
tempo se pensate bene ogni epoca di
cambiamento è stata caratterizzata da
una nuova corrente di pensiero che ha
rivoluzionato quegli anni
scrittori professori artisti donne e
uomini di cultura in generale che si
sono fatti carico della rivoluzione di
pensiero
purtroppo però nel corso del tempo la
rigida dicotomia tra scienza e cultura
fruibile a tutti ha portato alla grande
e cecità
l'abisso che oggi rivive scienza e
cultura è il motivo della nostra
razionalità
come è possibile quindi intervenire
rompendo questa recita cognitiva ed
esecutiva e soprattutto se abbiamo già
una soluzione perché nessuno sta facendo
qualcosa
questa domanda se l'è posta anche
l'unione europea chiedendosi come fosse
possibile trasmettere questo cambiamento
epocale a tutta la popolazione senza che
questa subisse un'imposizione dall'alto
quando la presidente della commissione
von der leyen vicepresidente timmermans
hanno lanciato il nuovo piano per
trasformare la nostra economia e la
nostra società denominato green deal
europeo si sono assunti la
responsabilità di rendere il nostro
continente il primo continente impatto
climatico 0 quello che è stato definito
green deal europeo è molto di più di un
semplice patto per il clima è dunque un
vero e proprio movimento che l'unione
europea ha lanciato cercando di
includere tutti in modo più orizzontale
possibile dai capi di governo hanno i
semplici cittadini
essere ambasciatore del grandioso
europeo vuol dire proprio cercare di far
attuare questo nuovo paradigma di
sviluppo a livello locale
che cos'è il green deal il green deal è
in assoluto il pacchetto di proposte più
completo mai presentato la commissione
in materia di clima ed energia ed ha
indicato la strada verso questa profonda
transizione
le azioni promosse attraverso i clienti
che saranno sicuramente ambiziose ma
sono anche l'unico modo che noi abbiamo
per salvare i nostri sistemi
sebbene 2050 ci sembra ancora lontano
tutto si gioca proprio nel decennio 2020
sentiamo spesso parlare del fantomatico
numero 15 gradi ecco questo la
temperatura di in aumento di 15 gradi
non è di certo il numero arbitrario su
cui possiamo negoziare e bensì un pene
tra i membri ovvero un confine
planetario oltre il quale raggiungeremo
una soglia di non ritorno se noi
continuiamo con questa tendenza
da qui al 2050 avremo una mente
temperatura di 3 gradi
per questo è necessario intraprendere
cambiamenti corali nella sfera economica
sociale e industriale
questo pacchetto di proposte è stato
passato da bruxelles ai nostri capi di
governo i quali sono i responsabili
dell'attuazione di grandi europeo a
livello locale altrimenti questo
rimarrebbe l'ennesimo trattato firmato e
mai attuato
oggi il nostro paese avrebbe già un
primo percorso da seguire ma il patto
europeo e anche una responsabilità
collettiva
aperta a tutti
innovatori imprenditori investitori
consumatori imprese famiglie e singoli
cittadini perché in realtà tutti noi
vedremo giovamento da maggiore spazio
dato alla natura freschi pulita città
più verdi e così via quindi questo non è
solo un obiettivo per salvare il nostro
pianeta ma è anche un modo per
incrementare il nostro finestre la
nostra salute mentale e fisica
la sfida al centro di oggi rimane quindi
l'azione
il nostro scopo è essere parte attiva
del cambiamento sociale e cercare di
contribuire a questo nuovo cambiamento
da quando nel 2015 il mio professore fu
capace di curare la mia cecità anch'io
cerco di contribuire al miglioramento
della società in cui vivo attraverso il
mio lavoro attraverso l'associazione di
rappresento e per quanto posto anche
attraverso l'attuazione del credito
europeo a livello locale
dunque però il riscaldamento globale è
in aumento
da allora mi sono chiesto e vi chiedo
anche a voi oggi chi è il responsabile
dello stato score di questi anni
la risposta è che in realtà io come
tutti noi siamo direttamente
responsabili sì perché come abbiamo
detto dobbiamo assolutamente attuare un
cambiamento culturale e bra a livello
pratico tutti noi possiamo parlare di
questioni climatici e curare la cecità
degli altri tutti noi dobbiamo rompere
la nostra rigidità cognitiva e la
piacevolezza del nostro quotidiano e
cercare di intervenire per un futuro
sostenibile
dobbiamo cercare di
cambiare questo sistema lineare in
sistema circolare ma siamo proprio noi
il motore di questo sistema di latte